and I will remind you the 2017 David
Pakman show calendars are now available
it is a comic book it is a coloring book
and it is also a calendar you can grab
yours at david pakman.com slash calendar
17 and you can get the calendar for free
with a yearly membership or just get the
calendar itself it's really it's
whatever you want really that's what I'm
concerned with you can have the calendar
autographed or not autographed the
choice is yours david pakman.com slash
calendar 17 I have some cringe-worthy
video of a trump energy advisor clearly
being clueless about how electricity
works the the background of this is that
during the main presidential debates
there were no real questions about very
important issues climate change two
minutes I think across the three debates
energy some references to energy but
nothing really substantive the
environment not much of a discussion
about the environment so there was a
sort of side debate between trevor
Howser and congressman Kevin Cramer
Trevor Howser is an energy adviser to
Hillary Clinton and Republican North
Dakota congressman Kevin Cramer is an
energy adviser to the Trump campaign and
they did sort of like a it's not really
a moot debate a mock debate it is it is
a debate it's just a debate that very
few people watched at the University of
Richmond's Law School and a question
came up about energy and it was
generally a pretty good discussion until
Cramer starts talking about neurons
during a question about energy and
electricity and clearly just has no idea
whatsoever what on earth he's talking
about and I'm gonna play that for you
now and then we'll talk about it
great question and with regard to the
federal role role I do want to get to
that because it is complicated when
you're talking about the movement of
electricity you know neurons go or
neurons want to go once they're on the
line right and and so Trevor talked
about decentralizing and that certainly
is part of it yeah but when you
decentralize and you're generating more
electricity than you can consume in a
particular area what do you do
extra electricity who's responsible for
it yeah me interstate-commerce loss you
have engineering challenges so it's it's
very introverted this is very
complicated and yeah study this you'll
find it's like how many tries to bring
in the other guy Trevor knows how
complicated this is neurons free to roam
free as the wind to go wherever they
want Trevor by the way looks completely
perplexed at this point as to what the
hell Cramer is talking about so the
mistake of neurons maybe isn't as bad as
this whole thing of they go where they
want to go I mean what on earth does
that mean and what does it have to do
with renewable energy
besides that obviously the you know the
neuron it was if he used the wrong word
we can chalk it up to that but then he
goes on to talk about the neurons go
where they want to go people can mix up
a word by mistake hell the other day on
the show pad I almost said erection
instead of election that can happen to
anybody but even once you've corrected
the word neurons here I don't know what
this guy's talking about and the one
thing that I hear from Trump supporters
is that even though he's ignorant on
certain policy issues
he'll delegate out responsibility and
get the best people to work for him
well this guy doesn't seem to even
understand electricity and his
environmental advisers don't accept
global warming in his defense you don't
really need to know science to take
bribes and accept lobbying money and
accept campaign contributions in order
to prevent progress on curbing climate
change and that's probably the actual
role of a trump energy adviser just to
figure out how to continue taking that
lobbying money this is just another
little preview of the United States
under Donald Trump vote November 8th
neurons flowing free is yet another way
in which we don't want Trump or anybody
that he would put around him being in
charge of anything in this country I'm
thrilled that today's program is made
possible in part by custom menswear line
indogene oh I'm very anxiously awaiting
the final tailoring on my custom suit to
be done I actually went into the Boston
Indo Chino showroom they have nine
showrooms across the country and I
worked with Chris I know nothing about
how to select the suit he held
me figure out what fabric do I want what
cut do I want what lining do I want do I
want one type of button or another one
type of pocket or another I know nothing
and Chris actually walked me through the
entire process about a month later I get
a call saying the suits ready come in I
went in tried it on loved it but it
wasn't yet exactly up to the indochina
standards which is also including some
custom tailoring which they measured me
for made a few small adjustments sent it
off to the tailor and now any day I
should be able to go in and pick up my
suit and even if you don't live near one
of the nine endo Gino showrooms you can
actually go on the endo chino website
and they tell you how to take
measurements that they need to custom
make a suit for you you enter them and
their software their website will walk
you through building a suit the way you
like it
and this week our listeners and viewers
can get any premium Indo Chino suit for
just 389 at Indo chino dot-com if and
this is a big if you enter the code
Pakman at checkout that's PA que ma n
that's 50% off the regular price for a
made-to-measure
custom suit plus shipping is free and of
course satisfaction guaranteed or your
money back
this is so great for me because when I
go to a store and you just basically
have to pick a suit off the rack and
then bring it to a tailor and sort of
explain to the tailor how does how do
you want it how's it feel working with
Kris at the Boston Indo chino showed no
room eliminated all of that drama and
nonsense
he helped me out they explained to me
the based on my stature which a lot of
people have questions about yes i am not
that tall what is going to be the best
suit and fit for me and our audience can
take advantage of this by going to endo
chino calm and use promo code pakman
that's PA que ma n